he is a king of comedy making a slap for
every 35 years the man the legend
welcome back Cedric the energy
well Cedric we are here at the news desk
will you hit the headlines for that oh
please
we're kicking it off with another comedy
Legend Carol Burnett her 90th birthday
says she's only got one thing left to do
George Clooney oh yeah
Carol jokes that George is
his thing on her to do list yeah and NBC
is celebrating her with a two-hour
special Carol Burnett 90 years of
laughter and love on April 26th
90. yeah
Cedric Rossi thoughts yeah are you going
to be doing stand up at 90. I would love
to man I think like who George Burns did
it like really late like that
yeah I would do stand up until I was 90
of course you know and George Clooney
why not yeah
let's just do the closer I love that she
has priorities you know whoever asked
that thought like what it like very
solemnly what is something you'd love to
do George Clooney yes yes you know she
had the perfect timing when she said it
too I love it maybe like it's all about
standing up until you can stand no
longer oh yeah yeah well you know you
could do like a lot of like OG stand ups
they'll just take a chair out on stage
so it's a sit down stand up right it's a
stand-up but you're sitting yeah you
know what I'm saying that's why they
break out the store the cool chair with
the economic chair yeah exactly stand up
sit down if George Clooney's there I'm
laying down that's all I know that's
right Rossi all right next up the New
York Post reports that you know bad dad
jokes might actually be good parenting
you all know what the dad joke is right
I do them here every day on the show for
you it's by definition a corny joke with
a punchline that's usually like a bad
pun or pretty obvious well experts say
that by telling kids jokes that are so
bad they're embarrassing dads are
actually pushing the limits of how
embarrassing like how much embarrassment
kids can take and showing them that it's
not fatal and do you think Cedric that
having a little humiliation in your life
as a kid prepares you for not as a
stand-up but like as a human yeah I
think so I mean you know I mean kids
because kids gonna go to school and they
they get pulled by you know their peers
and stuff so I think if you know if they
if at home you get a little bit of
ragging and you learn how to play the
dozens a little bit in a fun way sure
you can go to school and not be like
everything was you know you were bullied
by every little thing you know question
do you ever make jokes that are a little
kind of bad dad jokes
you stand by everything no no no no no
no no I've never had some jokes that you
know that like don't go over well like I
mean but but I I I don't know the bad
dad jokes I love the one about uh my
favorite ones like the the days on the
calendar I feel sorry for them because
their days are numbered oh God yes
that's
right oh I'm taking
I'm taking on that one nothing wrong
with a little corny humor around here
we're fine with it
we do like corn
and finally have you heard about
something called the martini Multiverse
well you're going to find out it's
today's food news
I'm scared so I love a good Martini at
the end of the day right and bustle
reports martinis have always been
customizable you can get them dirty dry
neat filthy yeah but now they become
full-on Martini meals yeah people are
serving up whatever they want in these
martinis and today we're trying look
look at this this is a chicken soup
martini
oh this is for you drew you have one
there I don't think you want okay how
about this Drew is not feeling the
chicken soup Martini so guess what I
have for you instead Drew this is a mac
and cheese Martini all right oh my God
that's so okay nice and thoughtful oh
wow the worst part about them you guys
you can't feel it oh wow they're cold
yeah well that helps okay I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna try it with you guys oh wow
okay chicken soup anyone else know about
this chicken soup Martini phenomenon oh
yeah okay I think it's just chicken
broth
foreign
it's Chicken Soup for the garbage can is
what it is it's cold and it tastes like
chicken soup you know what's weird is it
vodka here though no that's the problem
that's wood yeah that's what it is
that's what it needs you were the one
who didn't want to try it drew what do
you think
actually into it
got some real chickadee afternoon
I'm pleasantly surprised I really go for
the chick mac and cheese one though you
got to do it drew I can't I cannot
oh Drew yes oh God that's the one that's
gonna do it
really really good actually
um chicken teeny who knew
[Music]
foreign